[Music]
seriously this movie opens with a
soundless Touchstone Pictures logo then
after the second logo features eight
straight seconds of black sucker is
actively trying to make meeting
something's wrong with the blu-ray the
story you are about to see has been told
before a lot
nirisha unfortunately before we begin
there is a rather long boring prologue
which I will read to you now
you mean longer and more boring er than
already this play on to be or not to be
is Qatar but it represents the
high-water mark for the humor in this
movie so I'm sitting the fact that it's
all downhill from here
why is okay if these two hate each other
this much wouldn't I just wait til the
other left so they didn't have to see
them I mean I look around a good three
minutes when I venture out to get the
mail just to make sure I don't
accidentally partake in human contact
considering the contextual clues I'm
placing this in England meaning team red
is the one driving on the wrong side of
the road and I'm now firmly on Team
Monta blue also crazy complicated color
coordination clearly created to convey a
contentious character combat
conveniently right why is the sprinkler
Loom so upset here isn't this her sole
purpose in the garden yes you definitely
signed up to see an old as known dressed
in a Borat style onesie thong when you
decided this was the best use of your
monthly weekend with your kids why are
so many of these assholes upset about
their central functions little-known
fact this snail abuse officially started
the snail gnome Wars eventually
resulting in the mysterious deaths of
blue pock and biggie snails and also
resulting in the 2013 classic turbo make
up your mind movie earlier characters
couldn't separate themselves from the
props so why can't it just get off that
wheelbarrow the no lick maneuver all
those lose our act is a game that's blue
sister and the first of many times I
could make out that's racist bone in
this movie why does it take Juliet's so
long to come to life I mean the rest of
these fuckers have been running around
for several minutes that tree was your
father's pride and joy Wow miss Montague
seriously has a toilet with a tree
growing out of it right now your art is
this suburban Englander rural Alabama
also much like a Cars movie I'm forced
to consider how these gnomes procreate
do they have sex organs we hear them
clink against each other throughout the
movie so how would bumping uglies work
without breaking on I know my chores
edging trimming planting okay so in this
universe the garden gnomes maintain the
front yard fine
but we've seen that the humans aren't
aware of their sentience so
how did they think all that gets done
are they paying a dude named Brent to do
lawn maintenance and he's just pocketing
that cash when I'm doing she Brent what
an asshole
so rather than watching and trying to
catch her you're hiding your face from
your oncoming daughter shrapnel someone
just lost their shot at the better
gnomes and Gardens father of the Year
award that me could I'm not dead cut
precocious young female is held back by
the man until she proves that she should
be allowed to kick ass and an animated
kids movie cliche she's definitely not
delicate delicate hmm I'll show him
who's delicate man I delicate hope
delicate all this delicate repetition
delicate doesn't Ellicott have any
delicate impact delicate on my delicate
writing delicate from this delicate
point delicate on delicate did they just
say Thibault go just so they could rhyme
with no meow that's the lamest rhyming
I've heard since the summer of 99 when
LFO tried to rhyme Hornet with sonic
movie you get Bally freakin Parton to
voice apart and this is all you give her
and her character's name is Dolly gnome
did she intimidate all the creativity
out of you geez the first seven minutes
of this movie features several Elton
John songs and here I thought Kingsman 2
was the most egregious use of his music
they've been racing in a straight line
for quite a while now
so are they like in Wales at this point
wait his wheels connected to England
damn I don't know about the UK also zero
humans in the adjacent homes noticed
this very loud lawnmower chase damn it
not every animated movie is required to
have one of these slo-mo reaction shots
damnit so far we have objects coming
alive from Toy Story
the daughter won't play her role from
brave and now lightnings jump over the
car finished from cars only eight
minutes in and I think I've already won
my game but Pixar bingo
seriously what driver actually runs into
a fucking lawnmower it doesn't even slow
down shroom let's go kick some grass
nope not even having the animated
mushroom shaking its head at this
ridiculous plan excuses it from being in
the script but wouldn't the fish be able
to swim the gnomes are moving all sorts
of limbs and the Frog jumps around like
she's a rubber chicken so why does the
fish have a case of early onset rigor
mortis I'm hoping Juliet's Rod robbery
here is some kind of feminist commentary
but I'm also probably asking way too
much of the slapdash Shakespearean
knockoff junk in the trunk even if the
garden denizens picked up English from
hearing the
Capulets talk when the hell with this
phrase ever be used by a wrinkly old
English dude unless his name is Piers
Morgan I'm thinking of a movie it's one
word and starts with spider we would
have also accepted 2004 spider mm
spiders and 2010 spider hole first off
where the hell did these lasers come
from they definitely didn't dissuade
Nanette from bouncing all over the yard
a minute ago second off why the hell
didn't this much pink security I know
they're in a feud with the Montagues but
there's like holes in the fence that
they could get through hiding things
behind a fence only works if it's a
solid fence at least according to my
neighbors indecent exposure suit right I
love oh great this is all leading to
Noam dick jokes isn't it this goes on
for so long that I'm actively rooting
for Tibble to use his heaviest rock on
this little asshole but you're standing
right next to them this works
wheelbarrowing also I was doing this any
better wouldn't capulet know he never
had a strange wheelbarrow known
especially one that's blue in an Allred
yard sure maybe the spring from the
laundry line would get no me over the
fence but he's like 30 feet about the
house
what kind of juiced up elastic is in
these boxers ain't like the man slender
thing John again is this Gnomeo and
Juliet or the Lion King
luckily for the visibility of the scene
juliet waited for a bruce almighty moon
before she pulled her stunt damn dude I
know she's unknown but upskirting is
upskirting
this heart-shaped flower is also the
color purple which is red and blue
together because you should never settle
for one layer of obvious symbolism when
you can beat the audience over the head
with two also I know this symbolizes the
meet-cute but wise Gnomeo even reaching
for this flower we had no knowledge of
it until this very moment
who's your gnomey whose you know me whoa
who's you know me now I'm not kidding
including the obligatory Shakespeare
credit there are 16 goddamn writers on
this movie and this dialogue is what we
ended up with is any of this movement
possible within the laws of physics you
ask movie QA in physics it's about
genomes movie replies just can't be
love this over dramatic monologue from a
minor character goes on for so long that
I have expected the Frog to be voiced by
Kevin Hart how did these two clans
avoided each other for many years then
why is it so goddamn easy to get in and
out of the gates I wish I could picture
myself so 10 minutes ago here to go full
camo and sneak over the fence and dodge
lasers to get in here but now he just
wants us in at full volume even after
security orders the Code Red
not only does it take forever for any of
the gnome leadership to notice this
gregarious light show it doesn't awaken
a single human you look like a fun guy
terrible pun notwithstanding I'm pretty
sure this means she wants to fuck that
mushroom sweet sorrow wait Gnomeo had to
use some sort of contraption to release
the latch at the gate door so how does
Nanette do it so easily but don't
leaving the ground how could she do this
to Tibbets wishing well this is an
excellent question since even if these
two despise each other it's extremely
unlikely that a geriatric neighbor would
sneak into Capulets garden and tag is
yard art okay so if the gnomes are
cleaning this graffiti off after
Capulets sees it how does he think it
gets done one of the rules in this
between universe yeah yeah yeah we get
it the banana is a play on Apple but
it's a lazy one where's the bite out of
it why is it yellow instead of lit up
where's the planned obsolescence and the
overpriced replacements the NSA is your
Ruby too short to be considered
feature-length but you've run out of
animation money don't worry just do a
three-minute unnecessary montage of
gnome self care but without rendering
any backgrounds for it sure the spell
will feel like nothing else in the
entire movie and completely out of place
but at least it'll make the movie seem
longer and cheaper it's a 1950s
McAlister range one of the most annoying
parts of this movie is the fact that the
gnomes have a tremendous amount of
real-world knowledge with no explanation
for how they could possibly obtain it
casual Breaking and Entering is
extremely casual why are they coughing
therefore being gnomes damn it I don't
have lungs guys will be stupid you know
what it's like to be dreaded for Pudsey
Jess man this movie made some room for
its own personal Jar Jar
this mowers been sitting outside
unattended for several years but all it
needs is a little gas I mean petrol to
get to functioning perfectly
you saw the plunge and I guess miss
Montague just walked out saw a beautiful
flower that she didn't play it and
figured forget I guess that's how things
work sorry to put a damper on this
amphibian beauty moment but Paris does
realize this all ends with a gun to the
back of his pony cat right
Oklahoma is worth that Paris no cloaca
at all also the only way this could get
more uncomfortable is if Kevin Spacey
were actually involved this poor have
headed hippo is sentient this universe
is dark man is that your big move on a
second date you Wyndham dine em and then
spray them with weed killer well I've
never called it weed killer before but
if that's what you're into sometimes I
get a loo overexcited but I know I can
be a bit bad much are you seriously
trying to Pixar me right now with a
second-tier comic relief character we
just met five minutes ago the only tears
you're pulling here are from that giant
you know I just let out white
Featherstone hey come back you know for
a short ass kids movie this sucker has a
million subplots and none of them go
anywhere remember Juliet's dad's setting
her up with Paris I remember the frog
that wants to bone him how about the
conflict between Gnomeo and his mom a
lawnmower race that was skewer murder I
may not be a smart bird but I know what
love is
this forced force camp codes us to a
picture beautifully composed to give us
all the movie information we need but
exactly what kind of stalker is
responsible for actually taking this
picture how exactly did it get here and
this one too guys I know the movie wants
us to believe we're seeing a love story
right now but this feels much more like
a murder wall to me Featherstone's got
some sick secrets that I'm not ready to
learn movie tries to give us an up style
relationship montage about a couple
that's not even featured in the movie
Rosencrantz and Guildenstern Movers as
you like it whole movie tries to
Shakespeare reference so hard it might
pull a hamlet well that escalated
quickly so are they gonna do it right in
front of the mushroom and the Flamingo
Ouma's ed and red britain blueberry just
asked this now after the extremely loud
lawnmower battle damn does Gnomeo have
nobody from the Blues to come to his
defense the entire Red Army is attacking
and his only recourse is to make like
Monty Python and run away
Wow they really did it
they went full tragedy and killed no
Meah because they certainly wouldn't
pull some convenient nonsense where the
exact truck that hit him just happens to
also be carrying ceramic blue tea pants
falling out of the back because somehow
the back doors aw god damn it the humans
in this movie like this driver who
casually passes by while the sentient
gnomes are sentient in right out in the
open what happened to the traffic on
this road two minutes ago it was full
speed all lanes but now magic mushroom
over there has been hanging out in the
middle of the street for at least thirty
seconds and not a single vehicles been
seen either stratford-upon-avon has the
shortest rush hour in history or that's
some great able there is no way Gnomeo
wouldn't have noticed this giant
creature breathing above him well before
that slobber hid his face exactly what
kind of work is being done where this
loaders bucket is left completely
submerged for this long also how does
Gnomeo not see this machine before it
lifts him and juliet' gotten so much
trouble their dad went and krinkle der
this rain begins to fall when main
character is sound cliche is so cliche
i'm half expecting to hear Elton John's
cover of Hallelujah even though miss
Montague already selected the weaker
lawnmower and moved on with her life the
ad for the terrafirminator is still
front and center on her screen that's a
very aggressive pop-up if you have your
washing machine connected to a sewer
line big enough for a garden gnome to
Shawshank through your appliance in Rome
if any in the computer survived this
what is with the characters in this
movie
apparently everyone is immediately down
to one word plastique to use X plastic
ax so the delivery driver dropped this
mower off took it out of the box
assembled that then left it in the
middle of the yard even though miss
Montague wasn't home
man England is weird this Julius Caesar
reference would be a lot cooler if it
made any sense whatsoever for her to be
saying yeah which reminds me why didn't
anyone accept the shroom go out and at
least gather what they thought were no
miios remains which would lead them to
see that it was a teapot that would have
saved a lot of trouble in at least 20
minutes of my life
target blocks why does the lawnmower
have such a killing boner for Juliet I
mean there are a million other things to
destroy in this garden
Jesus Christ why is it only the fucking
mushroom that goes to check on things in
this movie this feud is over man I
haven't been this excited about a Maggie
Smith Michael Caine team-up since 1998
it's curtain call need to stretch the
run time of your cheap animated film
nothing better than a pre credits dance
party set to Crocodile Rock well except
maybe the sweet release of the credits
parting would be such sweet sweetness
the credits the credits my kingdom for
the credits wait Thibault still alive
after being smashed into smithereens so
why did I care about any of these
dickheads dying oh dude I know
Featherstone's lonely but a mail-order
bride isn't not the solution means no
man can cross it alright ah may I just
have some coke please you're only
supposed to blow the bloody doors off
[Music]
maniacal laugh I was just trying to keep
her safe I'm so sorry I failed you
trust
[Music]
it's sane in the brain I may not be a
smart part but I know what love is
[Music]